in the words of the immortal Rebecca
Black it's Friday I've actually already
made that joke - what news episode well
I also made a joke about the Cure it's
Friday I'm in love okay I have you
covered the IceCube hilarious nineties
comedy Friday in that case in the
immortal words of Ice Cube's hilarious
no he's comedy Friday it's Friday so a
big one this week was the release of for
tonight's battle royale a approximation
of the very popular game playing on
those battlegrounds so this one actually
came out about six days ago but there's
been a little word which is a word I
don't usually use but I feel like here
it's appropriate um blue hole who make
pub G obviously have a very similar mode
to fortnight's free battle royale
they're both you know survival of the
fittest you want to be the last one
standing there's a hundred players and
what has happened is blue halls been a
little passive-aggressive and saying
they might pursuit further action in an
official statement because of the
similarities between them their game and
the fortnight mode I do wonder what to
what degree can they pursue that so this
one actually gets a little more
complicated because within the last week
blue hole came out again and had a chart
with PC gamer and explained that it's
not so much that they're trying to
trademark dishonour as it is they
complicated relationship with Epic Games
okay because they use the engine they
use Epic Games engine also technically
they're business partners and what they
also got upset about is the fact that
when epic were promoting fortnight they
were saying oh we're huge pub G fans hey
we've got this mode oh boy a whole are
upset because they're saying they didn't
come to us they have created a merge
that's incredibly similar to our game
and we license
we are already licensing their engine
like paying them royalties and now
they're kind of using our game to
support a mode for their different game
yeah it's also I guess the thing that
fortnight has over
player knows battle grounds is fortnight
battle royale airs on consoles right now
you can go and play it on ps4 and Xbox
one battlegrounds hasn't
two consoles yet it's and it still got a
tentative release date of this year on
xbox you know from a consumer standpoint
you go to really great games apparently
according to the 1 million plus players
who already in that free fortnight mode
so why don't you guys let us know what
you think and we'll let you know if
there's any updates you know what I
don't like this what me no okay that's
good you Braves my self-esteem goodness
gracious what I don't like is running
but whatever mine doing is running in a
video game
wow what a segue Super Mario run is
released a new mode and a new character
Daisy which you can unlock now and the
only way to unlock Daisy is in the remix
ten mode which is pretty cool so
basically it's little tiny bite-sized
chunks of existing levels that you've
only got one chance to get through if
you die you move on to the next level
and you just play ten and it costs you
one toad rally ticket and it within each
level you can collect three coins that
get you into a loop box and you can get
stuff like a gold Bowser statue and a
big magic mushroom and stuff like that
Super Mario run still costs money is
that correct it does if you want to play
this new stuff then you this is the paid
version oh yeah so this is the paid
version so this is all this is all an
addendum to the paid version but there's
also a new world called art world star
or star world I don't know which one but
you know it's it's more challenging
levels and they're only unlocked by
completing challenges in existing levels
so for example you've got to get through
world 1/1 collecting only five coins or
you need to defeat Bowser as peach or
you need to complete three toad rallies
in a row successfully stuff like that
and then you get these new levels which
I've managed to unlock one and they're
they're pretty cool pretty cool so yeah
and if you can't wait for Mario what to
see I guess this is like a good stopgap
for the next month because it's just
Mario until you Mario Mario in exciting
news for those of you crossing your
fingers that stardew valley would indeed
be coming to switch it has been approved
by Nintendo yes developer chuckle fish
have come out and confirmed that they
don't like to say these things a hundred
percent in case uh in their woods
everything goes terribly wrong which is
why they don't like to bring up release
days
till they're really close to actually
bringing it out but they reckoned it's
about like 95% at this point and will
arrive on your switch and because they
don't like to talk about release dates
too early it should be coming sometime
pretty soon yeah and not only that
they're also working on multiplayer mode
of course which I think we've told you
about before there should be a pc beta
starting later this year on steam for
the multiplayer version of star G Valley
where you can hang out with your friends
you can all start a farm together you
can put things in lock boxes everything
you can get married is a crazy stuff
almost everything you can do in the
single player and that multiplayer mode
will be arriving on all platforms so
that's going to be coming to switch as
well yeehaw
Tallyho hi-ho silver other Western
platitudes Jake Red Dead Redemption -
got a new trailer this week we did
pretty exciting it's the new protagonist
as now has a name his name's Arthur
Morgan and it looks like it's gonna be a
pretty cool because off the movies
hanging out with the Dutch gang yeah I
mean I think the biggest thing to take
away is that the new playable character
will be at least it seems like the new
playable character is going to be Arthur
Morgan who was not mentioned in Red Dead
Redemption 1 and it seems like it's
going to be a prequel however I have a
few theories that it might span before
the first game during the first game and
after the first game okay why do you
think that there's a shot in the trailer
where you see a widow morning and you
see a kid talking to Arthur Morgan I
think that Widow morning is Abigail
Marston and I think that kid is Jack
Marston or here for you play as him at
the end okay okay okay but that's just a
theory I'm probably wrong people on
Twitter I've already told me I'm wrong
what are that have any other theories
about what you want to expect that we
can glean from this minute-and-a-half
trailer I think I think hisis will play
a role like in GTA 5 I don't think it'll
play as big of a role but I have a
feeling considering how well that worked
in in GTA 5 and you're still robbing
banks robbing trains like it just kind
of makes sense to have that carry over
you know but I don't think it'll play as
big of a role Red Dead Redemption to it
we haven't got a solid release date yet
either but it is gonna come out spring
at 2018 on ps4 and Xbox one so let's see
if Jake's right in about who knows six
months in a week that was just chock
full of big news like Red Dead
Redemption to Assassin's Creed getting a
discovery mode where you don't have to
fight anyone you can just go and look at
mummies
stuff Bahama yeah that's gonna be great
this one kind of flew under the radar
Final Fantasy 15 the director Hajime
Tabata has said they're gonna keep
supporting the game yeah 2019 it's
really interesting because uh Ignace was
supposed to be the lost content that
they were making one final fantasy 15
but Tabata has now said he's actually
really excited to just keep making stuff
for it and they want to fill in the
story they want to fill in bits that
they feel like could have been better
explained to better fleshed out and they
also want to conclude the story so
that's really cool that's intimidating
to me because I haven't found the time
that's what's intimidating to me about
Final Fantasy 15 already is it there's
so much to play ya know there's gonna be
more oh boy well I mean what's so great
about it is apparently all of this was
this decision was made in response to
Finn and feedback fans coming back and
being like how about like I wish that
was a little more here and a little more
there it's not often that a developer
this big with a game this big will come
back and be like okay yeah totally we'll
fix it up like we have all this DLC out
like there's so many different things
that came out for Final Fantasy 15 but
they want to continue supporting it and
continue bringing out new content and I
think that's really awesome by the way
that's everything we have for you this
week enjoy your weekend and do let us
know what you cared about this week down
below in the comments and this weekend
play some cuphead be like me yellow your
TV and then have your neighbors called
the police when they think you're saying
a swear word someone in your house when
it's really just you yelling in screen
or divinity is so hard you can get five
hours in and realize you have their own
team make up and you have to start again
and join HUD games this weekend
video games one supposed to be fun so
let's see if Jack's Jack so let's see if
Jake's right in about who knows six
months Jack's Jackson